hello reject nation uh you know what
John this is a music video why don't you
introduce this hello reject nation my
name is John Humphrey I'm Greg
it's a good impression of my energy
we're gonna check out a video today a
music video but not just any music video
we are going to check out a live
performance from arguably the biggest
musical group on the planet and that
would be I always forget what it stands
for it's like bangtan boys find the
scene it's behind the scenes I gotta
learn the region but we're watching BTS
live on the Melon Music Awards 28 teen
wrote it's yeah crow chickens you've
seen a couple songs on this channel
specifically we've reacted to a few of
their music videos on patreon as well
because that's what you do three times a
week you do music video reactions on our
patreon because most music video
reactions get blocked that's true here
on the YouTube hugging it I wasn't
explaining it for that purpose I wasn't
doing an expositional dialogue in hopes
that people will go to our patreon for
TV show reaction watch along as in q and
A's as well and other reward tears I was
just speaking in natural conversation oh
yeah I didn't think anything weird had
happened at all pts is tight yeah I'm
sure the same fans of this or knowing
the reference that definitely a huge
crush so yeah we got a ton more of fun
content over on the patreon I would love
you come check us out and if you want to
see the unadulterated version of this
video that's where you can do that but
for right now why don't we hop into some
BTS get our kpop on
the Melon Music Awards you know that is
is it the Fantana does he give those out
Anthony Fontana yeah she's like little
golden busts of his tiny melon head Wow
it's a state music this looks live yeah
yeah this is a video it feels like one
now I think they're just playing the
support of a crap
this feels like this do you think
they're happy I know you have to like
give your life over to this the use of
this love yourself
god precision man do an introduction mhm
I love one likes simple tricks like that
make all the difference
I mentioned this is top of watching
requests from Natalie door Oh Natalie I
should have known
yeah you will hold him to intro now give
you a proper shout out of the second
matter I just want to make sure she
didn't click off before the video yeah
they were the ones who are the mess who
is standing can't trust him now must be
so fun to be in that crowd
is even walking on BB I know I said I
think it's fake love we know this off
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
crowd shouting big whoop
they seem like they're really singing
Lisa rapping end
I feel like the chorus maybe has a track
under it like you're very difficult to
move like this fall sing
[Music]
I could be one of these guys hey there
seven and then maybe they need me god I
do yeah if you don't go never with curly
hair
Thanks crow tips
[Music]
Stage two we're gonna have sex with half
this audience are thing looks like a
hundred thousand girls each age get
three buses each for all the girls are
going to Vegas
oh yeah that's some summer flash driving
my man I don't think you're sick of the
fake love man
I feel like these are seven of the
sexiest people on planet earth right
like 12 hours a day they train yeah two
hours a day they're sleeping with fans
uh-huh big nap for an hour and then they
just start the day over yeah I want to
get their psychology the Jason which I
think this will do today yeah they're
gonna find some time to talk about it
I'm gonna break the fourth wall
Jagga do that
dude anything they do the crowd just
goes wild and no even this religious
kooky hoods what imagine contributive
thing they do or a music video - I'm
sure it's gotta be it's gotta be part of
the story man BTS music vids have a
story there's a BTS edition of
Assassin's Creed they're getting ready
to start
whoa how they do that they're gonna be
somewhere else entirely on the stage
they're gonna be some places possible
they're playing part - oh yeah this one
with Eminem dancer where's part one not
gonna understand when he lost I like the
flavor of this song
[Applause]
did the confidence behind these people
yeah man look he looks like he's just
lounging around he has two mics now I'm
sitting here going which one of those is
turned off right now I'm pretty sure
it's the one there all the way to if we
just get like five of our other four
closest guy friends we can do something
all we need at that point is the same
haircut it could be an advantage
conclusive Wow oh that is sexy
rest of the reactions could be me
failing to know get that her moves down
there needs to be a BTS like Darren's
dance proves instructional you know VHS
you can buy obviously can't do the leg
works right now I just holding my
microphone up over here
these guys say anxiety medically it's
gotta be Oh seems like a Gary rush
service stressful life let's try some
unit gets this off I think I'm gonna
take a hip hop class this year
like above dance yeah these guys days
when you're training yeah I believe that
was the origin story you see rap
monsters frame them all for one year
hey man even though I don't like
understand what they're saying I could
listen to these chants super catchy way
better than the boy bands in America I'm
like hyper sleek in terms of production
and stuff
there's something badass attitude too
you know like never like [ __ ] smiling
so heavy and cool melons they're like
what this these are some way favorite
parts of BTS videos when they're just
laughing and having fun together yeah
like every music video has a way L cut
their backs don't they they don't go to
sleep they just stand with their heads
down at the end of the night yeah but
don't fake love yourself yeah yeah don't
be a crow take it love love oh damn I
thought this crowds voice is gonna be
more strained in the actual singers of
the ship oh yeah
[Music]
like this smooth really behind me you
gotta be one with the beat they just
pass in the fan I know yeah throaty side
perfectly God
really great matching the motions of the
camera move
don't know how much rehearsal they one
day there will be a downfall of these
guys and I will laugh well the downfall
come when you start GTS keep in their
camp boys
Wow looks pretty yeah these backup
dancers need more credit like everything
that went into this show
say give me those guys we could be those
girls really those guys yeah I want
where this camera is I want that see
right as far away as possible
what
yeah
now there anyone look like they're
sweating they just glisten
[Music]
volunteer home cook I'm getting it guys
haha scanning it this is the true arc of
this a this isn't a reaction this is an
instruction sad part is when I watch
things like it's not myself this is
literally what I'm doing this is a
window into it
[Music]
I wonder if they would ever let me
borrow like $20 if you write to them I'm
sure
send him a tweet these guys must like
sing while working out for something it
seems like they're singing I feel like
some of it yeah and yeah the camera work
on this is really well rehearsed yeah
for a live event man yeah this looks
like this is a lot of time
I can learn that move for sure John give
you that
[Music]
yes I am that's what the sex appeal is
on the body language man combine that
with the flexibility and coordination
yeah
[Music]
it seems like they would have had to
hurt just that one performance alone it
seems like they would have to rehearse
that for months it's probably a week no
indeed yes and they choreographed all
the camera work
they made all the graphics oh man that
was really really impressive I mean I
feel like I can do 90% of the moves they
do yeah whatever yeah I mean in the
moves Department I think you could
probably best at least four to five of
them out of seven you know even though
they're a k-pop man I'm hearing Leeson
YouTube videos like movie channels
randomly bring up BTS they are so
popular I didn't know who they weren't
to the start getting requests here and
now I don't know maybe because I'm now
because we get requests my ear just
notices it more if people bring them up
it now I'm like wow more people I've
noticing really know who these guys are
a Korean pop band is crazy in the past
couple years especially it seems like
kpop has been blowing up and these guys
who are the ones I'm always hearing
about ubiquitous seven dudes singing on
earth I think right now every time the
camera cut to one of them throughout 20
whole minutes there's a section of this
massive crowd just losing their [ __ ]
[Applause]
they're actually real literally just go
he crossed to this side of the stage so
I could see hardly better now
but the crowd is gonna burst into flames
for me pure enthusiasm yeah I was
waiting for something in a really wide
shot at the very end like are they gonna
like everyone's heads gonna explode yeah
I think you start Massacre in the crowd
with it like an assault rifle
[Music]
BCS could get away with just me with
anything gotta get to the next level man
I mean if you gotta go if you gotta
ascend to the level of existence though
I'm not gonna make any jokes about
audience members going after the
performers on stage because that's not
stuff that's really happened
but we haven't seen it in reverse you
used as part of a I feel like the VTS
group is the only people that can
literally get away with like just go to
the crowd and bitch-slap in the [ __ ]
okay
it's like stabbing the crowd they're
just drenched in blood by the end of
this Melon Music Awards performance and
the crowds still loving them they can do
no wrong it's just the thing about them
man woman and I thought their set was
pretty good I mean they started with
like at least a song we both recognized
and they moved on to something that was
a little more like mid-tempo and had
kind of like a European or Spanish five
or something with like he could stick
guitars and the sort of more swingy
loungy vibe and then I liked that they
brought in that traditional element too
with all the different like fans and
dancers and you know like that and even
not being able to understand most of the
lyrics it was still pretty engaging you
know most I would say I didn't
understand all the lyrics they said a
couple things in English they can love
it was cool to watch this because it's a
live performance and the music videos we
usually have the lyrics on screen so we
can really pay attention to like what
they're even talking about is yeah and
then this one you just can't you just
absorb the energy of the music their
performances the prowess of them is
performance yeah because watching them
move without any like trick camera shots
or editing other than the obviously very
rehearsed live live around cutting but
someone in the room just happy what's
the wrong eat all the fans are gonna be
so many people to put this together BTS
is the center of it
of course and they are the
hardest-working ones presumably because
of the amount of effort of singing dance
rehearsal and the pressure is on them
primarily the man that like the backup
dancers
the production design of all this the
people in the control room you don't
even think about one there have got to
be like stage has got to be like 18
cameramen there's got to be wardrobe
people backstage there's so many people
involved in something like this that BTS
does deserve the most praise but there's
also like so many other people who put
blood sweat and tears into making sure
this performance revolving around them
turned out great
no they founded the Melon Music Awards
just so they could do this this
beautiful man pretty grateful Natalie
Doran thank you so much for requesting
us not today is actually coming to
California in July that's when John or
her are gonna have some fake a love
that's that's right we're gonna be CRO
tits together yeah and not try and be
what we're not oh yeah and I'm gonna sit
there in the corner watching yeah
jealous envious touching myself that's
really what I want the culmination of
this chain I can't get off to it Natalie
unless I'm very jealous
it's lots of some very healthy things in
my life oh yeah this is the moment in
the shadow where I'm desperately trying
to remember another BTS song title to
work into a pun and I just can't look
John before we shot a bunch of patreon
exclusive videos yesterday there was a
comment that I kept referencing about
how someone was upset that I don't make
as many dirty jokes as I used to
oh yeah that's more there's many sexual
jokes I used to and it's really haunting
me so so yeah if anyone's new to the
channel and the meaning Greg for the
first time it's just all pervert mode
now from here on out oh yeah but satire
it's not dick it's just who I really am
and I've been trying to suppress it
a comment whose name I can't even
remember gonna bring this out yeah
that's what the purpose of this is just
to take as many notes as you can from
the random strangers who have never
mentioned yeah yeah there's only listen
to the hate don't listen to the words of
encouragement of love like Natalie who's
always being so loving and always being
so kind wanting to interact with us
constantly she's just the best she's a
beautiful girl she takes care of a bunch
of really old people constantly for her
work she doesn't actually care about
them it's just but you know I imagine on
the inside there's probably a good
person yeah Shawn's gonna find out
that's right
that's right I'm going to you know fake
love together I'll ask you a few
questions a wingman John act shy but he
seals the deal anyway all right put it
put it will come put the theory to the
test that you'll come put something it's
been a while since I was like James Bond
the beginning of Skyfall really together
philander with any random women that I
have to talk to in order to make this
mission work it's gonna be especially
harder and these me two movements to
bring this all back I'm sorry yeah gotta
be appropriately perverted yeah that's
our docks subscribe to reject nation
click that notification about patriotic
talk about the top music video reactions
and reviews from John humps over there
plentiful go bombard him with more kpop
reactions because that's what his
passions really at yes today